hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about it's still on language
learning but it's it's uh about this
whole idea of
uh the world we live in today
and you often hear a lot of doom and
gloom
about the world we live in today it's no
good
and
and i came across this um
this tweet
from this person
who says something young people need to
understand about politics is that older
people struggle with change
in your 20s you imagine you're building
a fantastic groundbreaking new world
in your 40s to 80s you imagine the best
world ever was the one when you were 23.
okay
so that got me thinking i i immediately
tweeted back and said uh
you know i'm 72.
i think the world today is great
uh and people have this sense that
you know if you're 20 you think 40 is
very old
uh i once was in a discussion on twitter
or youtube or something where
someone was saying old people have more
trouble learning languages and i went
back and i said what is old to you and
the person came back and said 40.
i'm 72 and i don't feel any older than
when i was 20. okay in my mind
and i think there's so many things about
today
that are better
than before first of all statistically
there's less violence despite all the
stuff that's in the news and everything
else there's crime rates going down the
wars are less deadly
uh hopefully
we don't have a conflagration on the
korean peninsula
uh there are obviously issues
but there's so many things that are
better today but i should point i should
also say that it's pointless to compare
i can only live now i can't live 20
years ago i can't live 20 years into the
future i live today so i better enjoy it
and i've always felt that way if i'm
living in japan do i like living in
japan i'm living in japan i'm gonna like
living in japan
uh there's no point in saying gee would
be better if i were living somewhere
else so i tend to
try to enjoy whatever i'm into and of
course i'm into and i should point out
like why do i like today well just look
at me here i got my
computer over there you can't see it
okay and there's my computer i got my
ipad i got my ipod touch i'm making this
video on my iphone which helps me do
other things including telephone you
know called people
uh and it's so useful in so many ways
when i was a student i remember my first
year in france in grenoble grenoble
of course i was away from my father my
mother passed away when i was 16 but i
was away and every three weeks i'd get a
letter from my father
nowadays i'm in instant contact with my
family i have a son in his family in
london
i have a grand i have one granddaughter
at university another grandson is away i
can you know facetime them skype them
email whatever we're instantly connected
which is nice which is nice
and of course when it comes to language
learning here again like
yesterday
uh oh yeah so uh my car won't start
because the battery's dead
so i i get the roadside assistance
uh to come and
jumpstart my car but then the battery
still has nothing no juice in it
so i have to drive 40 minutes to the
dealer because my car is under warranty
even though i bought it as a secondhand
car
uh and so that i get them to replace the
battery so 40 minutes there 40 minutes
back
the whole time i'm listening to arabic
okay and i'm listening to these stories
that i have gone through many times now
reading and of course saving words and
phrases and and listening to the and
doing it sentence by sentence in
sentence mode on my app listening to
each sentence picking out words and
phrases doing the activities dictation
flash cards whatever and slowly
i'm starting to understand so i'm
charging along uh
charging my battery hoping to get to the
dealer so i can replace my battery and
i'm listening to stories in arabic that
i understand
and i've been at arabic now for whatever
five six weeks
and i'm learning arabic actually i'm
getting to a level where i can at least
understand it
quite quickly
and that's because of
again modern methodology modern
technology
you know the fact that i can do it on my
iphone i can do it on my ipad
uh i even do it on when i go and work
out i do it on my little uh ipod touch
here
uh i can even sit in the bathtub and i
hold my little ipod touch and i can
study arabic i can touch the little
words and and listen to it or whatever i
want to do
so there's all these now means i can uh
i can get on the internet and i can find
resources like
you know when i first started in arabic
i had to print out a list of all their
uh the writings uh you know letters
symbols if you want uh four different
forms of them
uh i was able to find a small grammar
book which i believed through a few
times not really trying to remember much
all these things are available to me um
you know i was just looking at this a
little earlier
so if i look at you know my past
five six weeks on arabic
in the last month okay because our
statistics at link don't go in terms of
six weeks but in terms of a month
in the past month i have listened to 27
hours of arabic 27 hours of arabic these
are our many stories we have 40 of them
right now another 20 will be loaded
uh you know in the near future the first
ten i understand them
uh the next ten kind some of them i
understand better than others and then
you know those that i haven't listened
to 50 or 60 times i don't understand
quite as well
but i have listened to 27 hours i have
read 10 000 words in arabic
in six weeks
putting in you know and i know uh well
in the last month i have added 320 known
words to my known word count i know
about 350 words in arabic and this
number is going to go up so in terms of
the things that i like to do
you know the availability of of means
you know and and even in terms of uh
connect people you know the sort of
polyglot community people who recommend
uh
resources to you
uh places to go
um
you know it's i feel connected as a
language as an independent language
learner i feel connected to other people
like ollie richards on facebook we had a
brief exchange
because he's also learning different
languages and he learned arabic and he
was in egypt and he said they were the
friendliest people he had ever come
across
and so that's encouraging okay maybe
i'll once i get my modern standard
arabic to a certain level maybe i'll
focus on egyptian arabic or
levantine arabic i just don't know yet
so you have that level of support again
this is the kind of community we live in
uh today so
today
not so bad
um
you know i could go on like uh
yeah
my wife and i like to stay uh fit
so and of course she studies stuff that
she finds on youtube she likes to make
uh sourdough brands so she finds all
kinds of different ways of growing these
cultures at home to make her sourdough
bread she has different people uh who uh
you know give her different ways of
working on her piano
she finds these exercise routines on
youtube we connect them to the tv and uh
you know we're all at the carpet and we
do these little workout routines at home
there's so many different things so
yeah i think that uh
first of all it's pointless to complain
and say that today is not as good as
yesterday
because today is all we have and we will
eventually have tomorrow and i'm very
optimistic about tomorrow i think that
uh
many of the problems that seem
overwhelming including environmental
problems
humankind will find a solution we'll
find ways to mitigate
and so i'm an optimist and i think it's
helpful to be an optimist because
i think it's it's enthusiasm curiosity
uh the desire to learn things
uh these are the things that um
impel us forward
and and a willingness to work with other
people and to uh
to uh cooperate and collaborate
uh which is very much uh the tone of the
uh
of the sort of internet uh language
learning community so
i'm an optimist
and i think that uh
never have conditions for language
learning been as favorable as they are
today
so uh and there's nothing wrong with
being 72.
so
thanks for listening bye for now i will
shut this down
[Music]
you